Bienvenidos a nuestra inmersión profunda en la
evidencia clínica de hoy. Vamos a desarmar un caso
clínico directamente de la base de datos de medsemiotics.
Y la idea es responder a una pregunta que, la verdad, de entrada
parece una locura.
Sí, porque desafía bastante lo que nos enseñan.
Totalmente. Queremos ver qué sucede en el razonamiento médico cuando
los signos, digamos los más obvios y clásicos de una enfermedad,
resultan ser estadísticamente inútiles.
Ah, ese es un punto fascinante, porque normalmente existe esta
expectativa de que la medicina funciona un poco como la ingeniería, ¿no?
O sea, causa y efecto.
Exacto. Si un paciente se cae, le duele la pierna, tomamos una radiografía,
vemos una línea blanca irregular en el hueso, señalamos y decimos, bueno,
ahí está la fractura.
Claro, tienes una prueba totalmente independiente que confirma la sospecha.
Pero cuando entramos en el terreno de la semiología clínica y la medicina basada en
la evidencia, especialmente con enfermedades hepáticas, esa
claridad radiográfica desaparece por completo.
Se esfuma. Y por eso nuestra misión en esta sesión
no es repasar lo básico que cualquiera puede leer en un
manual de patología.
No, para nada.
Lo que queremos es deconstruir exactamente cómo los hallazgos
físicos modifican la probabilidad pretest y por qué a veces
la estadística médica choca de frente con nuestra intuición.
Y ese choque ocurre precisamente porque, pues los clínicos estamos
entrenados para buscar certezas cuantificables.
Queremos el número duro.
Exacto. Queremos saber exactamente qué tanto peso tiene un síntoma para confirmar
o descartar una enfermedad.
Ajá.
Pero en este caso clínico que vamos a analizar, la evidencia nos obliga a
enfrentarnos a lagunas de información y a paradojas matemáticas que,
digamos, desafían la forma en que tradicionalmente diagnosticamos.
Bueno, para entender cómo la evidencia choca con estos límites,
quiero que pongas sobre la mesa los detalles de este caso socrático que
tenemos en las fuentes. ¿A quién estamos evaluando hoy?
A ver, tenemos a un varón de 26 años.
Y su ocupación es clave aquí.
Trabaja como ayudante de cocina en un restaurante.
Uy, ¿eso ya enciende algunas alarmas epidemiológicas?
Sí, sin duda. El motivo de consulta principal, o sea, lo que lo
trae a urgencias, es que desde hace dos días ha notado que su orina tiene un
color de té muy oscuro.
Y además, sus compañeros de trabajo le comentaron que tiene los ojos amarillos.
¿Y sobre los antecedentes?
Pues, al indagar, relata que hace aproximadamente un mes
regresó de un viaje a una zona rural.
Y ahí admite haber consumido agua sin tratar de un pozo.
Ok. Agua no potable hace un mes.
Ajá. No tiene antecedentes de consumo habitual de alcohol.
No toma ningún tipo de medicamento crónico.
Niega rotundamente el uso de productos de herbolario o suplementos.
Que siempre hay que preguntarlo en temas hepáticos, claro.
Sí, siempre. Y tampoco reporta conductas sexuales de riesgo ni uso de
drogas intravenosas.
A ver, si nos detenemos solo en ese motivo de consulta
y en los antecedentes, la mente de cualquier clínico que nos
escucha ya está corriendo hacia un diagnóstico.
Es casi automático.
Pero retrocedamos un poco al pródromo, a lo
que pasó antes de que el paciente se pusiera amarillo.
Ese es un detalle súper importante.
El paciente refiere que una semana antes de notar la orina oscura,
comenzó con un cuadro de malestar general insidioso.
Ajá.
Presentó astenia profunda, anorexia, algunas náuseas esporádicas
y una sensación febril que no llegó a cuantificarse con
termómetro.
Bueno, quiero hacer una pausa aquí y cuestionar un poco este punto.
Si miramos esa primera semana de forma aislada, o sea, eso parece un síndrome
viral inespecífico.
Sí, totalmente.
Podría ser influenza, un adenovirus o, literalmente, cualquier
gripe estacional.
¿Cómo justificamos siquiera la sospecha de que el hígado está fallando
en esa etapa temprana?
Es difícil.
Porque, digo, mucho antes de que aparezca la ictericia o la orina oscura,
si me llega la consulta el día 3 con fiebre y cansancio, yo no pienso en el
hígado.
Y estarías haciendo lo correcto empíricamente.
Exactamente. Si evalúas el pródromo de forma aislada, esos síntomas sistémicos
son compatibles con cientos de infecciones virales.
Claro.
La sospecha hepática en esta fase no nace de los síntomas en sí.
Este nace puramente del contexto epidemiológico sumado a la incubación.
El viaje y el agua.
Exacto. El viaje reciente y la ingesta de agua no tratada hace un mes
coinciden con el periodo de incubación típico de virus de transmisión entérica.
Pero siendo muy rigurosos, la sospecha real no se ancla
sino hasta que ese cuadro inespecífico culmina con el signo pivote.
La orina oscura.
Así es.
Lo cual nos lleva a la primera bofetada estadística que nos da la base de datos
de medsemiotics.
Al revisar la evidencia clínica, síntomas como la fiebre, la astenia y la
anorexia figuran como elementos de apoyo diagnóstico para la hepatitis viral
aguda.
Sí están listados ahí.
Sin embargo, los tres tienen una etiqueta que dice LRR
no medido, o sea, un cociente de verosimilitud
no medido.
Y para quienes nos escuchan y utilizan el teorema de Bayes en
su práctica diaria, pues sabemos que necesitamos ese cociente de
verosimilitud para tomar nuestra probabilidad pre-test y
convertirla en una probabilidad post-test, ¿no?
Claro, tras encontrar un síntoma.
Pero aquí no tenemos número.
¿Qué significa operativamente en la consulta que esto
sea un LR no medido?
Significa literalmente que existe una laguna enorme en la
literatura médica mundial. O sea, nadie ha publicado un estudio
prospectivo y riguroso que cuantifique de manera específica
esto.
Nadie ha medido cuánto cambia la probabilidad.
¿No? No sabemos cuánto modifican la fiebre o la anorexia, la
probabilidad de tener una hepatitis viral aguda, frente a otras causas de malestar
general.
¡Guau!
Sabemos por pura fisiopatología y por décadas de observación clínica
que estos síntomas apoyan el diagnóstico.
Sí, porque la viremia desencadena inflamación.
Exactamente. Hay una respuesta inflamatoria sistémica antes de que el virus
genere necrosis masiva en los hepatocitos.
Pero, digamos, no se les puede asignar un peso numérico.
Es un vacío puro en la evidencia.
Es frustrante, la verdad. Es como tener una brújula que te dice que
vayas al norte, pero no tiene marcados los granos.
Sí, buena analogía.
Así que no sabes exactamente cuánto desviar el timón.
Si los síntomas tempranos no tienen este peso numérico asignado,
imagino que el instinto natural de cualquier médico es esperar a que la enfermedad
avance.
Ajá, a que se vuelva visualmente obvia.
Exacto. Y buscar signos físicos contundentes en la exploración.
Pues, vamos a la exploración física de este paciente entonces.
En urgencias se registra una temperatura de 37.9 grados Celsius.
Febrícula, ok.
Se observa una ictericia franca y evidente tanto en las escleras como
en la piel.
El paciente además aporta una muestra de orina que confirma visualmente la coluria.
Bien oscuro como té.
Así es. Y en la anamnesis dirigida, añade que desde ayer
ha notado acolia. O sea, sus heces son de un color pálido, casi
blanco.
Interesante.
A la palpación del abdomen presenta dolor moderado en el hipocondrio derecho.
Y al palpar el hígado, se detecta un borde hepático romo que
rebasa el reborde costal.
Hepatomegalia, claro.
Y francamente doloroso para el paciente.
No se palpa el vaso y no hay estigmas de hepatopatía crónica como
arañas vasculares o eritema palmar.
A ver, detengámonos a deconstruir la fisiopatología
de estos hallazgos, empezando por ese hígado doloroso,
porque siempre me ha parecido curioso por qué duele un hígado
inflamado si el parenquim hepático en sí mismo carece de receptores
de dolor.
Ah, es que el dolor no proviene de los hepatocitos que se están
necrosando. Proviene de la cápsula de Glisson.
La membrana fibrosa que envuelve al hígado.
Esa misma. La inflamación aguda severa genera un edema tremendo en
el tejido hepático, lo que distiende rápidamente esta cápsula.
Y ahí están los nervios.
Exacto. Esa distensión aguda de las terminaciones nerviosas capsulares
es lo que genera el dolor en el hipocondrio derecho, y es lo que hace que el borde
se palpe romo y no afilado.
Ahora vamos con las estrellas del cuadro, digamos, la
coluria y la acolia.
Cuando aparecen juntas, como en este joven ayudante de cocina, me
gustaría que expliquemos cómo funcionan como un mapa anatómico del
problema de la bilirrubina.
Claro.
Hagamos una analogía visual, a ver qué te parece.
Para mí, el riñón funciona como un filtro de café de papel.
Si intentas filtrar algo que es puramente grasa, digamos aceite de motor,
el filtro lo bloquea.
Sí, no pasa nada al otro lado.
Exacto. Pero si filtras agua con azúcar, pues pasa directamente.
¿Cómo aplica esto a la bilirrubina y a la coluria?
Es una analogía anatómica y bioquímica muy precisa.
Cuando los glóbulos rojos se destruyen, liberan bilirrubina no
conjugada.
Y esta molécula es lipofílica.
Es, este, como tu aceite de motor.
Ajá. ¿No se disuelve en agua?
Exacto. Como no se disuelve en agua, tiene que viajar por la sangre unida a la
albúmina.
Y al llegar a los glomérulos del riñón, pues no puede filtrarse.
Por lo tanto, nunca llega a la orina.
Nunca. Ok.
Pero, una vez que el hígado capta esa bilirrubina, entra en juego la
enzima glucuroniltransferasa.
Esta le añade ácido glucurónico y la convierte en
bilirrubina conjugada.
Que esta nueva molécula sí es hidrosoluble.
Es tu agua con azúcar del ejemplo.
Perfecto.
Si por alguna razón esta bilirrubina hidrosoluble no puede
fluir hacia los conductos biliares y se acumula en la sangre, pasará sin
problemas por el filtro del riñón.
Tiñendo la orina de ese color pardo oscuro, la famosa coluria.
Así es.
Lo cual, clínicamente, la verdad, nos ayuda a descartar causas de manera
instantánea.
Aleja de inmediato cualquier causa prehepática pura.
O sea, si un paciente tiene una hemólisis masiva, destruyendo glóbulos
rojos por millones, tendrá mucha bilirrubina no conjugada en sangre.
Estará muy ictérico.
Estará ictérico, pero su orina será de color normal, porque esa
bilirrubina lipofílica no puede filtrarse.
¿Y la colia completa, el mapa aquí?
Sí, la colia ocurre porque esa bilirrubina conjugada
debería estar viajando por los conductos biliares hacia el intestino.
Que es lo que le da el color marrón a las heces al oxidarse a estercobilina, ¿no?
Exactamente. Pero aquí no está llegando.
El flujo está bloqueado ya sea porque los hepatocitos están tan inflamados que los
canalículos biliares colapsan o porque hay una obstrucción física más abajo.
Bueno, aquí tengo que ser un poco de abogada del diablo.
A ver.
Si la coluria y la colia son herramientas deductivas tan perfectas desde la
fisiopatología, si nos permiten ubicar el trastorno en la
excreción hepatocelular de una forma tan visual, ¿por qué nuestra
fuente clínica de medsemiotics también las cataloga con un LR no
medido?
¡Ay! Porque la elegancia fisiopatológica no garantiza la validación
estadística.
¡Auch!
Ubican el problema anatómicamente, sí.
Nos dicen que el problema está en la conjugación o en la excreción biliar.
Pero su capacidad aislada para distinguir específicamente una hepatitis
viral aguda, de, digamos, una coledocolitiasis o un tumor
periampular…
O sea, algo obstructivo extrahepático.
Exacto. Esa capacidad no ha sido cuantificada formalmente en estudios
amplios frente a un estándar de referencia eteológico.
Falta la data dura.
No existe en la literatura un ensayo riguroso que ponga a prueba el signo de la
coluria frente a la serología IgM para hepatitis A,
que nos diga algo como, la coluria multiplica por 4.5 tu
probabilidad pretest de hepatitis viral.
O sea, tenemos otra brecha enorme entre la utilidad
fisiopatológica diaria y la cuantificación estadística estricta.
Lamentablemente, sí.
Pero, fíjate, me confieso genuinamente sorprendida con otro dato
de la fuente.
Si la falta de números para la coluria parece una limitación muy
académica,
los datos sobre la simple detección visual de la ictericia son
directamente un ataque a la confianza de cualquier médico.
Totalmente.
Yo siempre he pensado que, pues, si un paciente tiene la bilirrubina alta, se le
notan los ojos amarillos y punto.
No hay mucha ciencia.
Todos pensamos eso.
La ictericia escleral suele considerarse el signo cardinal en la exploración
física. Sin embargo, los números reportados en la revisión de medsemiotics
obligan a reconsiderar nuestra agudeza visual.
Cuéntame de esos números.
Mira, con una bilirrubina sérica total de 2.5 miligramos por decilitro,
solo la reconoció el 58% de los examinadores clínicos.
Espera, ¿cómo? Eso significa que casi la mitad de los
médicos pasaron por alto la ictericia teniendo la bilirrubina ya por
encima del rango normal, que suele ser hasta 1 o 1.2.
Así es. Y el intervalo de confianza del 95% de ese dato
va del 33 al 80%.
Es altísimo el margen de error.
Y, fíjate, incluso si subimos la bilirrubina total a 3.1
mg por decilitro, que ya es un aumento considerable, apenas el 68%
de los examinadores logró detectarla visualmente, con un intervalo de
confianza del 46 al 85%.
En términos generales, cuando se evalúa frente al patrón de oro que es la
medición de bilirrubina en laboratorio, la sensibilidad y la especificidad de la
detección clínica de la ictericia rondan apenas el 70%.
A ver, estamos perdiendo a 3 de cada 10 pacientes
que genuinamente tienen hiperbilirubinemia si solo dependemos
de nuestros ojos.
Tal cual.
¿Por qué fallamos tanto en algo que parece tan
aparentemente visual y obvio?
Hay múltiples variables que la estadística agrupa aquí.
La iluminación de la sala es crítica, por ejemplo.
Claro, los hospitales tienen luces raras.
Exacto. Examinar escleras bajo luz fluorescente blanca o amarilla de
un hospital enmascara el tono amarillento en comparación con, pues, la
luz natural del sol. También influye muchísimo el tono de piel del paciente,
la congestión conjuntival concomitante.
Y, por supuesto, la experiencia del observador para distinguir entre la grasa
subconjuntival normal y un depósito verdadero de bilirrubina.
Sí, la pingüécula y todo eso.
Bueno, si nuestros ojos nos engañan el 30% de las
veces y carecemos de cocientes de verosimilitud útiles para
signos tan clásicos, la reacción natural de todos nosotros
será recurrir directamente al laboratorio bioquímico para buscar,
no sé, tierra firme.
Es lo más lógico. La fosfatasa alcalina está en 190
unidades por litro.
Y el tiempo de protrombina, medido como INR, es de 1.1,
lo cual es normal.
Ok, tenemos números muy contundentes.
Esto es un patrón de daño hepatocelular masivo.
O sea, transaminasas disparadas casi a 2,000 unidades,
bilirrubina conjugada por las nubes.
Sin duda.
Si tengo números, entonces asumo que, ahora sí, puedo usar una
calculadora bayesiana para determinar mi probabilidad post-test de hepatitis viral,
¿no?
Pues aquí es donde la fuente arroja la limitación más profunda y confusa de todo
este análisis.
¡Ay, no! ¿Otra vez?
Sí. El texto advierte explícitamente que no se puede calcular un
cociente de verosimilitud para estos laboratorios.
Y fíjate, usa un término distinto.
A ver.
Antes hablábamos de un LR no medido, pero para las
transaminasas, la fuente dice que es un LR no medible.
Espera, no medido frente a no medible.
Me tienes que explicar la diferencia detalladamente, porque a simple vista
suenan exactamente igual.
Sí, puede ser confuso, pero esta es probablemente la trampa
epistemológica más grande en el razonamiento diagnóstico moderno.
Wow, ¿ok?
Un LR no medido, como el que discutimos para la coluria o
la hepatomegalia, representa una falta de datos empíricos.
Nadie ha financiado ni realizado el estudio.
Pero en teoría, alguien podría diseñar un protocolo mañana, juntar a
mil pacientes y darnos el número.
O sea, es una cuestión de que falta investigación, falta voluntad o
dinero.
Exactamente. Por el contrario, un LR no medible
es un muro de contención absoluto construido por la lógica misma
del método científico.
¿Cómo así?
Es matemáticamente imposible de calcular debido a un fenómeno
conocido como sesgo de incorporación.
Sesgo de incorporación. Explícame la mecánica de
eso en este paciente en particular.
¿Por qué no puedo simplemente, digamos, tomar la
ALT de 1850 y ver estadísticamente
cómo predice la hepatitis?
Porque para calcular el rendimiento de cualquier prueba diagnóstica, necesitas
evaluar esa prueba de forma totalmente independiente frente a un patrón de
referencia, lo que llamamos el estándar de oro.
Ajá, hasta ahí estamos claros.
El problema es que el propio síndrome clínico de hepatitis viral aguda se define
médicamente por la presencia de inflamación hepática.
Y nosotros objetivamos esa inflamación como elevación de transaminasas e
hiperbilirrubinemia.
Ah.
Los hallazgos de laboratorio son parte constitutiva de la definición misma de la
enfermedad.
Claro. Entiendo la paradoja perfectamente.
O sea, si intento usar las transaminasas altas como una
pista para adivinar si el paciente tiene hepatitis, estoy cometiendo un
error lógico.
Exacto.
Es como, fíjate, es como intentar calificar la precisión y el
rigor de un examen escolar, pero permitiendo que el propio alumno sea
quien redacte la hoja de respuestas correctas antes de empezar a contestar.
Es un gran ejemplo. Obviamente, el alumno sacará un 100%,
pero esa calificación es una ilusión.
Evaluar un criterio diagnóstico contra una enfermedad que requiere ese
mismísimo criterio para existir, pues infla artificialmente la
sensibilidad y especificidad a cifras absurdas.
El sesgo de incorporación corrompe el cálculo matemático por completo.
Totalmente. Y la base de datos asume una postura muy rigurosa en
este aspecto. Nos dice, básicamente, que es preferible aceptar que el
LR es no medible antes que inventar o calcular un número viciado que
introduzca falsas certezas en el algoritmo mental del clínico.
¡Qué fuerte! Pero esto nos deja en una posición bien precaria
en la urgencia.
Sí, bastante.
Si las transaminasas en 1850 y la bilirrubina en 6.8
no definen la etiología por culpa de este sesgo,
porque, a ver, un patrón hepatocelular agudo así podría deberse a una
intoxicación por paracetamol,
a una hepatitis isquémica por un choque o a un brote autoinmune.
Cualquier cosa.
Entonces, ¿cuál es el verdadero juez final aquí?
¿Quién dicta la sentencia?
El único patrón de referencia verdadero, el estándar de oro independiente que
dictamina el apellido de la enfermedad, es la serología.
Los anticuerpos.
A, el antígeno de superficie, y la IgM anti-core para
la hepatitis B.
Y dependiendo del terreno epidemiológico, pues anticuerpos contra la hepatitis C
y E, claro.
Exacto. La semiología y la bioquímica básica arman el marco del
rompecabezas.
O sea, nos confirman que hay necrosis hepatocelular y colestasis intrahepática,
pero solo la serología nos dice qué agente disparó el daño.
Llegamos entonces a los resultados de este paciente.
El laboratorio reporta una IgM contra el virus de la hepatitis A que
resulta francamente positiva.
Ahí lo tenemos.
Ahora el diagnóstico etiológico es definitivo.
Fija que hemos transitado desde la inespecificidad del
pródromo viral, reconociendo nuestra incapacidad clínica para
detectar la ictericia en un 30% de los casos,
hasta chocar con el sesgo de incorporación en los laboratorios
básicos.
Ha sido todo un viaje metodológico.
Pero la inmersión no termina en la abstracción matemática.
El objetivo final de usar esta evidencia es tomar decisiones sobre la
persona de carne y hueso que tenemos enfrente.
¿Qué hacemos hoy con este hombre de 26 años?
Bueno, la primera decisión de peso es el sitio de atención.
Tenemos a un paciente con hepatitis A aguda confirmada.
Está alerta, responde con coherencia, su tolerancia a los alimentos
sólidos y líquidos por vía oral es buena.
Y lo más importante que vimos en sus laboratorios, tiene un INR de 1.1.
Ese dilema clásico de triaje.
¿Lo mandamos a su casa con indicaciones o requiere una cama de hospitalización?
¿Qué nos dice la evidencia para este caso?
Con el cuadro actual, el manejo es estrictamente de soporte y ambulatorio.
No hay antivirales específicos para la hepatitis A.
Se debe asegurar el estado de hidratación y, muy importante,
proscribir de forma tajante el consumo de alcohol o cualquier fármaco
hepatotóxico.
Paracetamol, fuera.
Cero. Pero el clínico debe prever en qué momento este caso benigno se
convierte en una catástrofe.
Existen criterios de alarma muy puntuales que indican que el hígado está
claudicando hacia una insuficiencia hepática aguda.
¿Y si alguno de estos aparece?
La decisión cambia de ambulatorio a ingreso hospitalario inmediato,
potencialmente en una unidad de cuidados intensivos.
Mencionaste el INR de 1.1 como un factor tranquilizador.
¿Por qué el tiempo de protrombina prolongado es el primer criterio de
gravedad al que le prestamos atención?
Porque el hígado sintetiza la gran mayoría de los factores de coagulación
dependientes de vitamina K, y el factor 7 tiene la vida media más corta de
todos, apenas unas 6 horas.
O sea que cae rapidísimo.
Si la necrosis viral es tan masiva que el hígado pierde su función de síntesis
hoy mismo,
los niveles de albúmina tardarán semanas en bajar debido a su vida media-larga,
pero el factor 7 se agota casi de inmediato.
Ajá, claro.
Esto hace que el tiempo de protrombina se prolongue rápidamente y el INR se
dispare.
Es nuestro mejor radar temprano de falla hepática fulminante.
Entendido. Falla de síntesis aguda.
¿Qué otros criterios clínicos nos obligan a ingresar al paciente?
El segundo es cualquier asomo de encefalopatía hepática.
Por mínimo que sea.
Sí, desde sutiles cambios en el ciclo sueño-vigilia o somnolencia
diurna, hasta confusión franca o la aparición de asterixis, ese temblor
aleteante en las manos al extender las muñecas.
Y para conectar un poco la fisiopatología, esa
asterixis y encefalopatía ocurren porque el hígado inflamado
ya no puede depurar el amoníaco que generan las bacterias en el intestino.
Ajá.
Ese amoníaco cruza la barrera hematoencefálica y altera directamente
la neurotransmisión cerebral.
Así es. Es una toxina endógena actuando sin control.
¿Qué más tenemos?
Los otros dos criterios de ingreso son más mecánicos, pero igual de graves.
La intolerancia persistente a la vía oral por náuseas y vómitos intratables
que pongan en riesgo la hidratación.
Y por último, un empeoramiento rápido, progresivo y
sostenido de la ictericia.
Como nuestro paciente no presenta nada de esto, se va a casa.
Ok, se va a casa.
Sin embargo, creo que estamos pasando por alto un detalle crítico de su
historia clínica que altera por completo nuestro plan de acción.
No olvidemos que este joven es ayudante de cocina, corta, prepara
y sirve alimentos para decenas de personas diariamente.
Uf, ese factor convierte un diagnóstico individual en una crisis
potencial de salud pública.
Sí.
La hepatitis A es un virus desnudo, altamente resistente en el medio
ambiente, y su vía de transmisión es fecal oral.
Clásico.
El virus excreta en las heces del paciente desde la fase prodrómica, fíjate,
días antes de que empiece a notar la orina oscura.
Que es justo cuando es más contagioso y él ni sabía que estaba enfermo.
Exacto. El riesgo de generar un brote epidémico a través de la contaminación
cruzada de alimentos es inmenso.
Entonces, ¿cómo se articula la acción clínica integral más allá del paciente
mismo? O sea, ¿qué pasos debemos tomar de inmediato ahí mismo
en urgencias?
Hay cuatro acciones innegociables.
A ver.
Primero, la notificación epidemiológica obligatoria a las autoridades sanitarias
locales para iniciar el rastreo.
Lógico.
Segundo, emitir una incapacidad que indique la suspensión laboral temporal y
absoluta de cualquier manipulación de alimentos hasta que pase la ventana de
contagio.
¿Nada de acercarse a la cocina?
Nada.
Tercero, educación exhaustiva sobre lavado estricto de manos con agua y jabón.
Y esto es vital porque los desinfectantes con base de alcohol no siempre inactivan
eficientemente a estos virus sin envoltura lipídica.
Ah, eso es súper importante.
El gel antibacterial no es suficiente aquí.
¿Y qué sucede con los contactos cercanos?
Compañeros de cocina, familiares que viven en su misma casa, ¿cómo
intervenimos médicamente en ellos?
Ese es el cuarto paso.
Evaluar la profilaxis post-exposición.
Tenemos dos herramientas, la vacuna contra la hepatitis A o la
administración de inmunoglobulina.
¿Y de qué depende usar una u otra?
La decisión depende de la edad, del estado inmunológico del contacto y del
tiempo transcurrido desde la exposición, que idealmente debe ser menor a dos
semanas.
Ok.
La vacuna confiere inmunidad activa, estimulando al cuerpo a
crear sus propias defensas. Pero en pacientes mayores de 40 años, o
inmunocomprometidos, o aquellos con enfermedad hepática crónica subyacente,
preferimos usar la inmunoglobulina.
Que provee inmunidad pasiva inmediata, me imagino.
Así es, aportando anticuerpos neutralizantes ya formados para
bloquear la progresión del virus.
Es asombroso cómo tirar del hilo de una simple queja
sobre orina oscura termina activando mecanismos moleculares de
virología y un protocolo tan complejo a nivel comunitario.
La medicina nunca opera en el vacío.
Para ir cerrando este análisis profundo de nuestras fuentes, quiero
sintetizar el concepto clave que quienes nos escuchan deben llevarse para aplicar
en su práctica de mañana.
Adelante.
El mensaje fundamental es que la audiencia clínica no debe sentirse
frustrada por la falta de cocientes de verosimilitud numéricos en un cuadro
clínico clásico. La lección profunda de esta base de datos es que, en
medicina, la ausencia de un número también transmite información
metodológica crucial.
Sí, nos enseña a reconocer los límites de cada herramienta
diagnóstica. La semiología de la hepatitis viral aguda, este,
evaluar el pródromo, detectar la ictericia, confirmar la coluria y
la acolia. Todo eso sirve de manera magistral para plantear la
sospecha del síndrome.
Y localizar de forma anatómica el bloqueo en el metabolismo de la bilirrubina.
Exactamente.
Pero, a pesar de toda su elegancia fisiopatológica, no
sirven para alimentar calculadoras bayesianas precisas, ya sea
porque los estudios pertinentes nunca se hicieron y el LR no está medido,
o porque la naturaleza misma del diagnóstico incurre en un sesgo
de incorporación, haciendo que los resultados de laboratorio sean estadísticamente
no medibles.
El apellido de la enfermedad, la etiqueta viral definitiva, le
pertenece de manera exclusiva a la serología.
La clínica sigue siendo la brújula que orienta la sospecha inicial, pero
debemos ser muy conscientes de que es el laboratorio serológico quien aporta el
mapa detallado para confirmar la etiología.
Y bueno, quiero dejarlos con un pensamiento final, una provocación que
surge precisamente de esas áreas grises en la literatura que exploramos hoy.
A ver.
Hablamos de la imposibilidad de calcular la probabilidad post-test debido a
estos sesgos.
Pero el teorema de Bayes requiere un punto de partida.
Una probabilidad pre-test.
Claro, el ancla.
Así que les pregunto, ¿cuál es realmente la probabilidad basal, la
prevalencia exacta de hepatitis viral en adultos que se presentan
espontáneamente con ictericia en nuestro entorno clínico específico?
Uf, esa es la pregunta que desencadena todo el raciocinio posterior.
Y es un dato crítico que según las bases de datos de evidencia aún no está
sólidamente registrado en muchos sistemas de salud.
Esto significa que todo nuestro andamiaje diagnóstico inicial está
condicionado por una prevalencia que la mayoría de las veces
estimamos a ciegas.
Basándonos solo en nuestra experiencia empírica.
Así es. Es una invitación para que quienes nos escuchan mantengan su
escepticismo siempre activo frente a la literatura.
A veces, las aguas más oscuras del diagnóstico, esas donde las
certezas numéricas fracasan, son precisamente el lugar donde el juicio
clínico estructurado es insustituible.